teilen statt kaufen und ein
wirtschaftssystem das nicht mehr aus
unternehmen und angestellten besteht
sondern aus gemeinschafts verbänden die
weltweite kooperieren darauf steuern wir
zu wenn wir dem amerikanischen ökonomen
kulturkritiker jeremy rifkin glauben
schenken was aber bedeutet dass wir die
unternehmen was für uns konsumentinnen
und wer gewinnt und wer verliert
diese fragen diskutieren ich heute in
berlin mit jeremy rifkin harry ging
selbst die erfolgsverwöhnte schweiz wird
derzeit vom schlechten
konjunkturprognosen eingeholt ist das
nach ihrer sicht auf diese globalen
unsicherheiten zurückzuführen oder
findet da schon ein großer wandel statt
wir erleben gerade eine fundamentale
umwälzungen der globalen wirtschaft ein
neues wirtschaftssystem betritt der
weltbühne die sharing economy und die
kollaborativen kommen es ist das erste
neue wirtschaftsmodell seit dem frühen
neunzehnten jahrhundert mit dem
kapitalismus und dem sozialismus
das ist ein historisches ereignis die
share economy und die kollaborativen
commons gedeihen entlang der tausch
wirtschaft und des kapitalistischen
marktes mal kooperieren sie mal
konkurrenzieren sie sich ich nehme an
dass der kapitalistischen markt noch bis
zur mitte dieses jahrhunderts existieren
wird weil er fähig ist sich einige
dieser commons einzuverleiben
aber er wird nicht mehr die einzige
option sein wir werden ein duales system
haben schwanken wir etwas aber man
wartet eigentlich auf die große erholung
wird die jetzt kommen oder wird die gar
nicht kommen bis wir in ihrem jahr 2050
sind im neuen system als angela merkel
deutsche kanzlerin wurde bat sie mich in
den ersten wochen ihrer amtszeit nach
berlin zu kommen um sie zu beraten wie
man in der deutschen wirtschaft
arbeitsplätze schaffen könnte
meine erste frage war frau kanzlerin wie
wollen sie die deutsche die europäische
die globale wirtschaft im endstadium
einer energie eher noch wachsen lassen
tatsache ist dass die zweite
industrielle revolution des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts am ende ist
fossile und nukleare energie werden
immer teurer
die marktpreise schwanken und bei den
bisherigen technologien die diese
energien umsetzen wie etwa der
verbrennungsmotor oder die zentrale
stromversorgung haben wir das potenzial
ausgeschöpft die wirtschaft auf der
ganzen welt schwächelt
jugendarbeitslosigkeit und ungleichheit
beim einkommen nehmen zu dies alles ist
ein hinweis dass das zwanzigste
jahrhundert vorbei ist wir müssen unsere
wirtschaft bis zur mitte des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts neu
organisieren
in ihrem buch die null grenzkosten
gesellschaft beschreiben sie ja dass der
kapitalismus an sein ende kommt weil wir
so produktiv sind dass wir die dinge
eigentlich sozusagen gratis abgeben
können wie geht das
wer kann dinge gratis abgeben hier
produziert zuerst möchte ich wiederholen
dass der kapitalismus nicht am ende ist
er wird weiterhin gedeihen aber auf eine
völlig andere weise als wir es bisher
kennen wir entdecken da ein paradox das
tief eingebettet ist im kapitalistischen
system und sich bis jetzt nicht
manifestiert hat dieses paradox hat
ironischerweise zum erfolg der
unsichtbaren hand des marktes geführt
heute erleben wir den erfolg der
unsichtbaren hand des marktes und dieser
wird uns zu einer nahezu null
grenzkosten gesellschaft führen und zu
einer neuen wirtschaftsform der sharing
economy und zu den kollaborativen kommen
grenzkosten sind die kosten für die
herstellung eines zusätzlichen stücks
oder einer dienstleistung nachdem sie
die fixkosten bezahlt haben
ich lehre an der wharton school der
ältesten wirtschaftshochschule der welt
und ich unterrichte führung
kräfte aus aller welt wir lehren dass
ein guter unternehmer immer auf der
suche nach neuen technologien ist damit
die produktivität gesteigert die
grenzkosten gesenkt und billigere
produkte und dienstleistungen hervor
gebracht werden können und damit der
gewinn aus dem konsum ihrer güter den
investoren schöne profite beschert der
optimal am markt ist der verkauf zu den
grenzkosten niemand von uns hätte in
seinen wildesten fantasien damit
gerechnet dass die technologische
revolution eine so extreme produktivität
entfalten würde dass wir diese
grenzkosten für gewisse nicht für alle
produkte auf nahezu null reduzieren
würden so dass wir sie potenziell gratis
abgeben könnten
in dieser situation befinden wir uns
gegenwärtig alle großen revolutionen der
geschichte haben einen gemeinsamen
nenner neue kommunikationstechniken zur
effizienteren organisation der
produktionsprozesse verbinden sich mit
neuen energiequellen zum effizienteren
ablauf der prozesse und mit neuen
logistischen errungenschaften für den
effizienteren transport der güter
denn diese technologien auf einer basis
technologieplattform zusammenwirken
verändern sie das wirtschaftsmodell dazu
ein paar beispiele
man hatte sozusagen die eisenbahn
zusammen mit dem telegraph der so
plötzlich es ermöglicht der über weite
strecken auch märkte miteinander zu
fliegen zu finden
das sagen sie dieses muster wiederholt
sich heute eigentlich wieder einfach auf
einer anderen ebene
so ist es und im neunzehnten jahrhundert
kam die dampfkraft unter telegraph die
revolution der kommunikation ging einher
mit dem aufkommen billiger kohle und der
dampfmaschine und wie sie sagen brachte
dies die lokomotive und das nationale
eisenbahnnetz hervor
damit gelangt der übergang vom lokalen
zum nationalen markt es entstanden
nationalstaaten um diese prozesse zu
verwalten dies war die erste
industrielle revolution im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert an die zweite wiederum
kommunikation energie und transport es
entstanden die zentrale
elektrizitätsversorgung und das telefon
später radio und fernsehen
diese kommunikationstechnik gehen einher
mit billigem öl mit dem
verbrennungsmotor und neun
transportfahrzeugen auf nationalen
straßennetze diese zweite industrielle
revolution ist im niedergang begriffen
deshalb schwächt sich die wirtschaft ab
was wir nun kommen sehen ist eine dritte
industrielle revolution mit ihrer
konvergenz von kommunikation energie und
transport in ihr werden die sharing
economy und die kollaborativen commons
aufkommen das internet mit dem wir alle
so gut zurecht kommen diese
kommunikationstechnik verbindet sich nun
mit einem gerade im entstehen
begriffenen internet auf der basis
erneuerbarer energie und bringt ein
automatisiertes transportlogistik
internet zur bildung eines sogenannten
super internet des internets der dinge
was passiert was passiert in diesem
super internet diese drei internet
bilden ein super internet sie schicken
sensoren aus in die ganze welt zurzeit
sind es etwa 13 milliarden sensoren
es gibt kleine sensoren in der
landwirtschaft die beobachtenden obst
und getreide wachsen und daten an das
super internet der dinge senden es gibt
sensoren in fabriken in lagerhäusern
verteilzentren sensoren auf
intelligenten straßen in
verkaufsgeschäften und schließlich im
smarthome wo wir sensoren auf allen
unseren einrichtungen haben
es werden kontinuierlich daten an die
drei internet gesendet
bis 2030 werden wir 130 trillionen
sensoren haben welche die ganze welt
vernetzen jedes gerät jeder maschine
jeden menschen wir kehren unser
zentralnervensystem nach außen
jeder von uns hat dann ein
zentralnervensystem das mit dem planeten
verbunden ist das mit unserer
lebensweise verändern
wir werden leben als ein
menschengeschlecht auf einer erde
was aber ist mit der datensicherheit dem
privatleben dem cyber terrorismus
gewisse institutionen werden auch
versuchen dieses neue super internet der
dinge zu monopolisieren wenn wenn sie
das so beschreiben die leben wie ich
stehe morgens auf und mein sensor merkt
schon dass ich jetzt langsam wach wehrte
er macht mir die richtige stärke kaffee
gehe ich irgendwie raus und mein sensor
verfolgt mich und weiß wo ich wo ich
dann bin und diese daten werden irgendwo
gesammelt bei denen die daten werden uns
allen erlauben völlig offen zu sein und
zu wissen was läuft in der wirtschaft
nicht nur in den großen vertikal
integrierten firmen alle daten sind für
alle menschen abrufbar
lassen sie mich erklären wir haben
bereits den 0 grenzkosten effekt gesehen
wir haben im laufe der letzten 15 jahre
mit dem kommunikations internet seine
wirkung auf ganze industriezweige
gesehen das ist keine akademische
weisheit
es begann im jahr 2000 mit einem kleinen
musikdienst namens napster millionen
junge leute bauten darauf ihre eigene
software mit deren hilfe sie ihre musik
untereinander teilen konnten
zu beinahe null grenzkosten sie machten
es gratis und umgingen einfach die
musikindustrie
dann machten hunderte von millionen
junger leute ihre eigene youtube videos
sie wurden zur plus users zu produzenten
und sie produzierten zu beinahe null
grenzkosten und teilten ist miteinander
ohne copyright sie umgingen die
filmindustrie
dann begann die ganze junge generation
ihre eigene nachrichten zu teilen mit
news blogs und stellte ihre kenntnisse
wikipedia zur verfügung
das hat bewirkt dass diese riesigen
vertikal integrierten mächtigen
kommunikationsmedien und
bildungsunternehmen des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts einbrachen
die plattenindustrie schrumpfte die
film- und fernsehindustrie erlitt
einbußen zeitungen und magazine gingen
ein
das 0 grenzkosten phänomen hat das spiel
verändert es befinden sich milliarden
von menschen gleichzeitig im netz die
ihre eigenen informationen und
unterhaltungs beiträge produzieren und
sie zu nahezu null grenzkosten teilen in
der schwering economy in den
kollaborativen commons unter umgehung
der traditionellen handelsplätze des
kapitalistischen marktes
ich teile einige dinge und käufer einige
dinge
das trifft auf alle menschen zu gewisse
dinge gibt es nur am markt aber ich bin
zum beispiel im internet wie jeder mann
und ich schreibe jeden tag blogs die
teile ich gratis mit millionen anderer
anstatt nachrichten auf traditionelle
weise zu verbreiten das tue ich tag für
tag
lassen sie mich sagen worum es
eigentlich geht es gab einmal die
annahme dass das 0 grenzkosten phänomen
insgesamt auf das informations und
nachrichten sowie auf das verlagswesen
begrenzt sei und dass es eine brandmauer
gebe und dass das 0 grenzkosten phänomen
nicht von der virtuellen welt durch
diese brandmauer in die welt der
physischen dinge dringen werde
doch genau dies geschieht mit dem super
internet der dinge wenn man das energie
internet und das transport und logistik
internet dazu nimmt sie fragen mich was
ich mit dem super internet anfangen kann
gehen wir von einem neutralen netz aus
dass nicht monopolisiert ist durch ein
paar große telekom kabel und internet
firmen
das ist nur eine annahme und sie wissen
es aus dem buch ich ringe damit da kommt
noch ärger auf uns zu die annahme geht
von privatsphäre datensicherheit und
transparenz aus alles nur annahmen was
sie und ich und der rest der menschheit
tun können
wir gehen auf das internet der dinge und
haben alle dinge zur verfügung die auch
den großen firmen zur verfügung stehen
wir benutzen unsere eigene technik
unsere kleinen smartphones und computer
mit all ihren apps und wir können die
analysen aller datenströme nutzen und
unsere eigenen algorithmen kreieren
genau wie google
wir können also unsere produktivität
steigern mit gewissen grenzkosten wir
können alle physischen güter mit
erneuerbarer energie auf 3d druckern
hervorbringen und wir können sie in den
kollaborativen commons zu beinahe null
grenzkosten teilen genauso wie wir es
heute mit unterhaltung information news
und wissen tun
das bringt einen großen wirtschaftlichen
wandel sprechen ja von den medien
einerseits das ist das was wir kennen
von von youtube und so aber sie sprechen
ja auch den 3d drucker an der alles
mögliche produziert den wäre
nicht den nicht mehr neun unternehmen
haben sondern denen wir auch bald einmal
zu hause haben werden für unsere hobby
gegenstände und so die frage ist ja
schon wenn wir das tun sie sagen 000
grenzkosten das heißt wir verkaufen
nicht mehr haben gratis verdienen werden
noch geld der verdiente noch geld lassen
sie mich das klarstellen sie sagen wir
würden den kapitalismus beenden
in meinem buch sage ich immer und immer
wieder der kapitalismus wird nicht
verschwinden
er wird lediglich die weltbühne teilen
müssen mit der sharing ökonomie und den
kollaborativen commons mal im
zusammenwirken mal im wettbewerb mit
diesen sie müssen sich also eine hybride
wirtschaft vorstellen nicht entweder
oder sondern ein sowohl als auch dazu
zwei beispiele der 3d drucker und die
energie sind zwei reale dinge wir haben
heute hunderttausende hobbys tausende
soziale unternehmer oder kleinbetriebe
drucken ihre eigenen 3d produkte aus zu
beinahe null grenzkosten diese nutzen
also bereits das super internet der
dinge und laden gratis software herunter
um diese produkte zu kreieren
denn diese software gehört allen und es
gibt keine probleme um das geistige
eigentum und dann verwenden sie
rezitierte material aus der umgebung
plastik altpapier altmetalle und
schmelzen es einfach ein nahezu null
grenzkosten es ist müll die software im
drucker steuert dann schicht um schicht
den aufbau eines realen gegenstandes
dieser kommt wie von zauberhand heraus
mit beweglichen teilen das ist bereits
tatsache und das interessante daran ist
dass dieser 3d drucker nur ein zehntel
des materials verbrauch dass eine fabrik
benötigt denn es gibt keine schnitt
abfälle
das produkt wird aufgebaut bereits
werden 3d drucker übrigens mit
erneuerbarer energie zu beinahe null
grenzkosten betrieben und bald werden
gedruckte 3d produkte auf den markt
kommen aufgedruckten 3d vehikeln das
erste automobil aus dem 3d drucker wird
soeben an der welt technologie messe in
chicago vorgestellt
sehr schön italienisches design es wurde
von einer handvoll junger leute in einem
labor ausgedruckt diese dinge geschehen
also bereits und wir müssen uns vor
augen halten dass 1980 keine computer in
den schulen standen heute fängt jedes
dreijährige kind damit an
und wenn es fünf jahre alt ist
produziert und teilt es längst
informationen und unterhaltung zu nahezu
null grenzkosten bald werden in jedem
schulhaus 3d drucker stehen nicht erst
in 20 jahren das hat schon angefangen
und jedes schulkind wird in fünf bis
zehn jahren seinen eigenen kleinen 3d
drucker betreiben das geht sehr schnell
zu sagen werden wir auch alle unseren
kleinen 3d drucker mit uns herumtragen
ganz bestimmt es ist bereits im gange
und zeigt ein exponentielles wachstum
es wird etwa gleich viel zeit brauchen
wie das kommunikations internet vor 24
jahren entstand das world wide web
seither hatte die menschheit zeit sich
an smartphones und computer und den
ganzen fluss von informationen und
unterhaltung zu nahezu null grenzkosten
in der share economy zu gewöhnen
es wird weitere 24 jahre dauern bis die
kleinen kinder in der schule jede art
von realen gegenständen produzieren und
austauschen
zu nahezu null grenzkosten in den
kollaborativen kommen
doch nun zum nächsten noch
interessanteren thema der energie in
europa gibt es millionen menschen
kleinunternehmen und wohnquartiere die
ihre eigene sonnen und windenergie
produzieren zu nahezu null grenzkosten
deutschland liegt er weit vor produziert
werden kann also im moment ist es noch
ganz weit weg von null kosten
das stimmt nicht ganz nur zum teil in
deutschland geschieht folgendes es gibt
einen einspeisetarif wir sonnen oder
windenergie produziert erhält bei der
einspeisung etwas mehr als den
marktpreis das schafft einen anreiz und
was die sache nun sogar wettbewerbsfähig
macht ist die städte verbilligung der
technologie so dass die windenergie geht
es nach wenigen jahren schon mit
traditionellen energie gleich zieht und
die sonnenenergie ist auch balczuweit in
einigen ländern ist sie es schon in
deutschland produzieren millionen von
menschen ihren eigenen strom mit sonne
und wind eine million gebäude wurde zu
klein kraftwerken bereits 27 prozent der
elektrizität in deutschland kommen von
sonne und wind bis 2020 sollen es 35
prozent sein
an einem tag im mai dieses jahres wurden
sogar 75 prozent des stroms zu null
grenzkosten hergestellt so dass den
ganzen tag negative preise resultierten
darum geht es also kurzfristig müssen
sie dafür bezahlen
die kraft clark und netzbetreiber
überwälzen einen teil der kosten in der
monatsrechnung auf die kunden
das ist nicht viel aber es ist da wenn
wir jedoch in den nächsten paar jahren
diesen übergang vollziehen werden alle
die energie zu nahezu null grenzkosten
bekommen
der verkaufspreis für elektrizität in
deutschland ist den sturzflug der
endverkaufspreis hält sich noch für die
kurze zeit des übergangs und wer stellt
all diese energie her
es sind nicht mehr die großen
stromkonzerne es sind millionen kleiner
player
leute wie sie und ich die sich in
elektro genossenschaften zusammen tun
in quartier eigenen unternehmungen die
vier großen stromkonzerne produzieren
weniger als sieben prozent des stroms
sie sind aus dem spiel
es läuft also wir mit der
plattenindustrie und den millionen von
jungen leuten die ihre eigene musik
austauschen und mit den zeitungen
zeitschriften und im fernsehen
die großen stromkonzerne erleben nun die
auswirkungen davon dass sie millionen
von kleinen playern in genossenschaften
zusammen tun und strom zu null
grenzkosten produzieren
fazit ist die sonne ist gratis man kauft
den sonnenkollektor die sonne schickt
keine rechnung man kauft die windturbine
den wind gibt's umsonst
es gibt keine fossile oder nukleare
energie die mit dieser beinahe gratis
energie mithalten kann 3d drucker
drucken mit abfall war
nicht wegschmeißen und nicht wissen
wohin damit und die energie wird quasi
löst unser klima problem mit anderen
worten habt dann haben sie auch keine
angst vor dem klimawandel das löst sich
auf diesem weg von selbst ich habe mich
mit dem klimawandel seit den 70er jahren
beschäftigt wie viele meiner kollegen
unterschätzte ich das tempo des
klimawandels die erschreckenden
auswirkungen auf das klima sind schon
jetzt eingetroffen 100 jahre bevor wir
sie erwartet aber was ich allen die uns
zuhören sagen möchte das schlimmste am
klimawandel ist die veränderung des
wasser zyklus auf unserer erde die erde
ist ein wasser planet ohne wasser können
wir nicht leben für jedes grad erwärmung
infolge des industriell bedingten
klimawandels absorbiert die atmosphäre 7
prozent mehr niederschläge vom boden
die hitze wird die niederschläge
schneller in die atmosphäre zurück was
zu mehr extremen wetterereignissen führt
extreme schneefälle im winter
dramatische überschwemmungen im frühjahr
mehr dürre im sommer heftigere
wirbelstürme unsere ökosysteme können
die radikalen ausschläge des wasser
zyklus nicht mehr verkraften aller
wissenschaftlichen studien besagen dass
die sechste auslöschung des lebens auf
der erde begonnen hat zuvor hatte es im
laufe von 450 millionen jahren fünf
weitgehende auslöschung des lebens
gegeben
und jedes mal kippte die chemie des
planeten sehr schnell und ließ alles
aussterben
es dauerte jeweils rund zehn millionen
jahre bis zur wiederherstellung der
biodiversität
wir befinden uns in der sechsten
auslöschung des lebens und ich möchte
allen eltern sagen wir verlieren
möglicherweise noch vor ende dieses
jahrhunderts bis zu 70 prozent aller
formen des lebens das ist das
jahrhundert ihrer kinder und
kindeskinder
um dem entgegenzutreten müssen wir wie
sie sagen eine null grenzkosten
gesellschaft werden dann können wir
reale güter nahezu ohne grenzkosten
produzieren und verteilen weil wir fast
kein material verbrauchen und vieles
rezitieren und die dinge die wir in
dieser 0 grenzkosten gesellschaft
herstellen teilen wir immer und immer
wieder in der sharing economy und in den
comments wir teilen autos über
carsharing unsere wohnungen über er
bmw und couchsurfing wir verbrauchen
weniger rohstoffe und sobald die ganze
energie erneuerbar ist sind wir die
kohlenstoffe und das co2 los der beste
weg den klimawandel zu vermeiden ist
also der übergang zur 0 grenzkosten
gesellschaft ich weiß nur nicht ob wir
das noch rechtzeitig schaffen aber es
gibt keinen plan b plan b würde bedeuten
dass wir im zwanzigsten jahrhundert
verharren
und das wäre wohl das baldige ende dazu
zu dieser 0 grenzkosten gesellschaft und
zu dem internet der dinge und sind 3d
drucker über das wir jetzt bereits
gesprochen haben und sprechen sie ja
auch sprechen sie auf einem
kollaborativen zeitalter von diesen
bekommen von diesen talenten wie wir sie
in der schweiz nennen seit sehr langer
zeit wir kennen das aus unseren alpen
aus unseren werken wurden
das land sie sind die erste journalistin
die das erwähnt verbleiben wir mal hier
sie wissen dass ich es im buch erwähnen
viele meinen dass es nur zwei arten von
wirtschaft gibt entweder den
kapitalistischen markt oder eine
regierung oder eine kombination von
beiden in der sozialen marktwirtschaft
doch halt es gibt eine institution schon
seit 1000 jahren und zwar eine
demokratische institution genannt die
commons die alm enden
da lernten den menschen als soziale
wesen dass es ihnen zum besten gereicht
wenn sie die kreativkräfte die
ressourcen und den ertrag miteinander
teilen und fehlverhalten maßregeln
nirgends gibt es dafür ein besseres
beispiel als in den schweizer
österreicher und deutschen alpen seit
1000 jahren sind zwei drittel der alpen
zum teil privat und zum teil allmend
kooperationen wo wiesen wasser und die
wälder zur gemeinsamen nutzung
zusammengelegt werden sie funktionieren
gedeihen und sind nachhaltig und die
menschen leben in zwei systemen den
marktwirtschaftlichen und dem
korporativen danke also dass sie die
erste journalistin sind die das
aufbringt
sie beschreiben diese elemente wie wir
sie eben kennen und elinor ostrom die
den nobelpreis 2009 hat das ja auch sehr
genau untersucht und sie kommt aber auf
ein paar dinge warum die eben
funktionieren und sie funktionieren
deshalb weil man klar
begrenzen hat also es geht jetzt in
diesen fällen geht es um ein stück land
es geht um eine alte und die hat ihr
ende
das ist klar definiert man sie definiert
er klar wer davon gebrauch machen kann
man kontrolliert den gebrauch man
überwacht sich gegenseitig und man hat
ganz klare sanktionen
mir leuchtet ein dass das sehr genau
funktioniert ich weiß wo sie
hinauswollen
wie geht das in einer globalen
gesellschaft und das interessante an dem
was er in ostheim sagt sie hat gezeigt
dass diese agenten seit 1000 jahren in
der ganzen welt vorkommen nicht nur in
den alpen überall haben menschen diese
demokratischen einrichtungen geschaffen
und sie haben ohne einander zu kennen
die gleichen regeln angewendet weil
diese am sinnvollsten waren man teilt
das gibt sanktionen für vergehen
man trägt verantwortung für die nächsten
generationen usw
was für uns heute interessant ist sind
die aussichten auf hochtechnisierte
globale kommend mit anderen worten das
super internet der dinge bestehend aus
dem kommunikations dem energie- und dem
transport und logistik internet erlaubt
uns auf globaler ebene unterhaltung
information nachrichten erneuerbare
energie und unsere 3d produkte
auszutauschen
wir können also die uralte institution
der allmend aktualisieren
sie hat nicht nur dörflichen charakter
sondern taugt auch für das globale und
so geschieht es jetzt auch ist ja wie
machen sie wenn sie das in einer
globalen gesellschaft machen wie machen
sie den ausschluss wie organisieren sie
den ausschluss und die überwachung
das wird große auseinandersetzungen
geben in meinem buch werfe ich diese
frage auf wird das super internet der
dinge zu einer demokratisierung von
allem führen oder zur monopolisierung
von allen die da sind die interessen von
telekomfirmen von kabelnetzbetreibern
energieversorgern sogar von google
facebook und twitter und was das
internet so offen und erfolgreich machte
ist dass es netzwerk neutral konzipiert
war
wenn sie und ich also ins internet gehen
zahlen wir unseren internet anbieter wir
können ins netz mit nahezu null
grenzkosten und haben den gleichen
zugang wie großfirmen niemand bleibt
draußen
einige große firmen des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts wittern hier möglichkeiten
das internet der dinge zu kontrollieren
die telekom und netzbetreiber aber wir
müssen auch die googles und die
facebooks beobachten ich liebe google
das ist eine wundertüte
wir nutzen es jeden tag aber wie ist das
eigentlich mit google und facebook
sie haben diese commons geschaffen damit
wir alle unsere informationen
nachrichten und unterhaltungen teilen
können
die firmen des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
wurden alle verdrängt wie hand google
erfolg hatte
doch was geschieht wenn google das
portal für das wissen der ganzen welt
ist oder wenn wir jede kommunikation
über facebook tätigen müssen und im
gegenzug nutzen sie unsere kreativen
inhalte und daten und verkaufen sie an
dritte zu werbe- und anderen zwecken
es sieht ganz so aus dass die googles
facebooks und twitters die potenziellen
monopolisten des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts sind sie kommen schon wie
globale versorger daher man muss sie
also regulieren
wir wollen sie nicht verlieren denn sie
gaben uns diese großen commons und wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass diese commons
offen netzwerk neutral transparent und
daten sicher bleiben und dass wir vor
cyber terrorismus sicher sind das ist
ein riesenkampf der wird uns die
nächsten 30 40 jahre in atem halten kein
sonntagsspaziergang
aber ich bin zuversichtlich denn auch
die großen plattenfirmen konnten
millionen junge leute nicht daran
hindern ihre musik auszutauschen
sie versuchten es die verlage konnten
die jungen leute nicht daran hindern
nachrichten blogs auszutauschen und die
fernsehindustrie konnte die junge nicht
davon abhalten ihre eigenen videos zu
gestalten und zu tauschen ich vermute
das wird auch mit der energie und vielen
anderen bereichen geschehen
der weg ist nun voll aber schließlich
gelingt ist das wirtschaftsleben zu
demokratisieren
jeder kann unternehmer sein gleichzeitig
aber unterstützen und helfen wir
einander als teil der gemeinschaft
es ist eine reise zum besseren division
aber trotzdem wenn wir uns überlegen wie
wir dorthin kommen
ich meine sie haben gesagt google kann
facebook an das können die neuen
monopolisten werden was tun wir
gegenwärtigen unserer wehr
schaffts ordnung gegen monopolisten wir
versuchen durch wettbewerbsrecht diese
einzuschränken
das heißt wir brauchen eine behörde die
das wiederum beobachtet die das
überwacht und die das funktioniert und
wie geht das in einer in den commons in
den kollaborativ kommen werden wir uns
da einfach friedlich und harmonisch
finden um solche regeln aufzustellen
allein das wird von hardware und sie
wissen dass ich die eu berater und ich
habe das privileg für und mit der eu den
masterplan für die dritte industrielle
revolution zu entwerfen
noch diesen monat treffe ich in brüssel
mit mikros der eu kommissarin für
digitale agenda zusammen
die eu hat weltweit die
themenführerschaft übernommen was
datenschutz datensicherheit und
monopolist muss betrifft
wir sehen ja jeden tag die
auseinandersetzung zwischen der eu und
google
täglich wird um datenschutz und
datenströme gerungen
hier liegt die eu weit vorn und ich
hoffe die usa und andere länder werden
nachziehen und sich um eine wirksame
regelung bemühen aber etwas möchte ich
noch sagen es geht nicht nur um google
jedem google steht ein wikipedia
gegenüber wikipedia ist non profit und
die sechstgrößte website der welt
da tauscht die ganze menschheit
kostenlos ihr wissen aus so dass wir
hier das wissen der welt versammelt
haben und jedem airbnb dem kommerziellen
netzwerk des wohnungs teilens steht ein
couchsurfing gegenüber das gratis ist
oder nehmen sie über das zurzeit in
aller munde ist nach all dem hält dass
diese firmen aus dem silicon valley
einnehmen wird es ein böses erwachen
geben denn die technologie ist frei
verfügbar
wir sehen bereits dass in europäischen
städten die fahrer sagen was sollen wir
für google fahren und ihnen den profit
abliefern
warum machen wir nicht unsere eigene
website wir können die gleichen gps
daten verwenden und genossenschaften
bilden sowie beim deutschen verband der
energie genossenschaften werden sich
überall auf der welt die besitzer von
autos in genossenschaften zusammentun
werden bank kredite aufnehmen ihre
ressourcen zusammenlegen und sie ein
kleine commons vermieten die mikro
commons
damit werden sie klar wettbewerbsfähiger
sein als ein großunternehmen aus dem
silicon valley und das wird sich in den
nächsten ein zwei jahren zeigen die
großen unternehmen werden ins schlingern
kommen dass wir ein rechtssystem haben
das nicht nur existiert und dass solche
dass die datennutzung beispielsweise
begrenzt und sichert sondern dass auch
fähig ist das auch durchzusetzen
und da stellt sich natürlich schon die
frage was machen wir mit google die
daten sind bei google
wir können schon gesetze erlassen und
sagen ihr dürft sie so zu ja verwenden
wir aber brauchen wir auch die
funktionsfähigkeit ich weiß wohin ihre
bedenken zielen es braucht eine art
globale behörde die uno ich weiß nicht
immerhin hat die uno alle drei player an
einen tisch gebracht die öffentliche
hand die privatwirtschaft und die
zivilgesellschaftlichen organisationen
bis jetzt verlief das kollegial war
global verwaltet und netzwerk neutral
wir bräuchten vielleicht in zukunft eine
neue globale behörde die sich damit
befasst das wird ohne zweifel zu
schwierigen auseinandersetzungen führen
ich glaube aber sobald die technologie
da ist und globale commons entstehen und
jemand versucht sich diese für
kommerzielle zwecke einzuverleiben
werden einfach dank der vorhandenen
technologie neue unabhängige commons
gebildet sobald die technologie leicht
anwendbar ist wie bei über gesehen
entstehen genossenschaften die das
besser machen also es sind nicht einfach
die bösen großunternehmen gegen alle
anderen
es gibt viele große unternehmen die
gutes leisten ich will nicht dass google
facebook und twitter verschwinden denn
sie haben kommen es für die sharing
economy hervorgebracht aber ich möchte
sichergehen dass sie reguliert und
verantwortlich gemacht werden
dasselbe mit dem carsharing werfen wir
einen blick auf das carsharing das ist
fasziniert ich bin viel älter als sie
ich wuchs auf als das auto noch als
kernstück des jahrhunderts galt wer kein
auto hatte existierte nicht in der
marktwirtschaft
die jungen von heute machen sich nichts
aus dem besitz eines autos
sie suchen nicht im besitz sondern den
zugang sie wollen mobilität und machen
sich nichts aus dem auto und für jedes
geteilte auto es sind millionen die
autos teilen
entziehen wir der produktion 15 wagen in
d3 internets machen es möglich sie gehen
ins internet mit dem smartphone und
klicken eine car sharing site an diese
sucht im logistik internet über gps
innerhalb von drei minuten einen wagen
in ihrer nähe
sie fahren zum bestimmungsort und
anstatt dass sie eine rechnung bekommen
wird der betrag automatisch von ihrem
paypal konto abgezogen
bis in zehn jahren werden die autos
elektrisch fahren in paris ist dies
schon der fall
und ein großteil der energie hat beinahe
null grenzkosten in zehn bis 15 jahren
werden die autos für losfahren das gibt
es schon
und hier senken wir wieder die
grenzkosten schließlich kommen die autos
in lokalen fabriken vom 3d drucker und
das sind keine wilden spekulationen das
geschieht bereits in den communitys
nicht 50 jahre zu überspringen sondern
nicht zu fragen was passiert jetzt
weil wenn wir davon sprechen dass die
autoindustrie bis zu einem drittel will
mich du bist sogar zur hälfte oder noch
mehr einbricht dann bedeutet das
zunächst einmal das unternehmen
untergehen das menschen arbeitslos
werden dass sie keinen lohn mehr haben
dass sie dafür sich nichts mehr kaufen
können sie die dinge sind ja noch nicht
gratis ein teil der dinge sind grad ist
aber die frage ist schon was passiert in
dieser übergangsphase
ich bin froh dass sie von der
autoindustrie sprechen was mit ihr
passiert ist dasselbe was mit der
schallplattenindustrie den zeitung von
buchverlagen und mit dem fernsehen
passiert ist larry burns nummer zwei bei
general motors seit 34 jahren im
ruhestand hatte die entwicklung des
autos der zukunft unter sich elektro und
brennstoffzellenfahrzeugen
er lehrt heute an der universität von
michigan und machte dort eine studie
über n aber eine mittelgroße stadt ich
erwähne sie im buch schon beim jetzt
bestehenden internet der dinge
kommunikations energie und logistik
internet zeigt seine studie dass wir
heute mit 80 prozent weniger fahrzeugen
und den übrigen im carsharing eine
bessere oder mindestens die gleiche
mobilität hätten
daraus lässt sich schließen von der
milliarde autos busse und lastwagen auf
der erde
wenn wir 800 millionen nicht benötigen
der rest wäre carsharing und würde mit
erneuerbarer energie zu nahezu null
grenzkosten betrieben stellen sie sich
die einbrüche in der autoindustrie vor
aber was machen wir mit den menschen die
ihre jobs verlieren weil das sie
sprechen fordert dritten industriellen
revolution in der ersten haben sie ihre
jobs verloren in der zweiten haben sie
ihre jobs vor und jetzt wird es wieder
so sein
und was stellen sie sich vor was in
diesen nächsten zehn zwanzig jahren
wurde wo der wandel den sie beschreiben
wirklich greift was da passiert wer
arbeitet noch wo irgendwo mit sein geld
und wofür geben wir noch gerne raus
wie sie wissen habe ich 1995 ein buch
über das ende der arbeit geschrieben
darin sagte ich und das geschieht ja
jetzt dass wir fast alles im markt
automatisieren fabriken haben wir schon
automatisiert die fabrikarbeiter sind
überflüssig geworden china mexiko usa
alle automatisieren fabriken damit
eliminieren wir aber nicht nur arbeiter
mit all den programmen algorithmen
robotics werden auch angestellte
überflüssig vom realen handel ist nicht
weit zum virtuellen der mit
automatisierten systemen betrieben wird
und nun sind auch die wissensarbeiter
dran denen dem wir gesagt haben bilde
dich werde ein wissensarbeiter doch
jetzt mit künstliche intelligenz und
algorithmen brauchen wir nicht mehr alle
juristen buchhalter und radiologen wir
sind effizienter mit all den
automatisierten technologien langfristig
werden wir im 21 jahrhundert zu einem
weitgehend automatisierten markt
übergehen
was also tun mit den arbeitskräften wir
haben eine neue studie über
arbeitsplatzverluste in 40 jahren also
über zwei generationen da gibt es einen
silberstreifen denn wir müssen ja die
ganze infrastruktur von der zweiten zur
dritten industriellen revolution planen
und aufbauen weltweit müssen wir in
jedem land den wandel von der fossilen
und nuklearen energie zu den
erneuerbaren
belgien vollziehen wir müssen alle
gebäude nachrüsten damit sie
energieeffizient werden
das ist eine riesen menge arbeit für die
bauwirtschaft in den nächsten 40 jahren
millionen von jobs für hilfs- und
facharbeiter
außerdem müssen wir das stromnetz eines
jeden landes in ein energie internet
umbauen
gewaltige möglichkeiten für die
elektronik und die it-industrie und eine
menge jobs für millionen menschen
und dann kommt auch noch das
transportnetz wir müssen aus dummen
straßen intelligente straßen machen
weg vom verbrennungsmotor und hin zum
hybrid antrieb und zum gps leitsystem
mit führerloser lenkung
das sind zahllose arbeitsplätze in der
logistik und der transportindustrie wir
brauchen 40 jahre um in jedem land diese
infrastruktur aufzubauen und wir können
morgen früh damit beginnen zu
investieren und arbeitsplätze zu
schaffen
die alternative ist im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert zu verharren bei wachsender
arbeitslosigkeit und einer sterbenden
erschafft das langfristige problem ist
diese systeme sind intelligent so bald
wird die plattform für das internet der
dinge für die dritte industrielle
revolution einführen kann es sich selbst
verwalten bei wenig technischer wartung
dann fragt sich was die menschheit noch
zu tun hat wir erleben seit zehn jahren
eine gewaltige migration der
beschäftigung von der marktwirtschaft zu
den commons zur sozialwirtschaft zum
dritten sektor zum non profit sektor
warum weil wir da soziales kapital
schaffen das können maschine nicht
maschinen können dinge herstellen
im non profit sektor geht es um die
menschheit alles vom non profit
krankenhaus über schulen tagesstätten
altenbetreuung umwelt-engagement kultur
und sport es ist ein riesiger sektor und
wenn man ihn ab schafft wird die ganze
kultur die gesellschaft zusammenbrechen
in den usa liegen bereits zehn prozent
der arbeitsplätze in diesem sektor und
in den fortschrittlichsten ländern
europas sind es bereits 15 prozent
wir müssen die jungen menschen für zwei
arten von beschäftigung vorbereitet
wir müssen sie für dieses internet der
dinge ausbilden und wir müssen sie
ausbilden für die schaffung von
sozialkapital in der schering economy
und arbeiteten
bleiben wir bei diesem wort
sie habe neben social entrepreneur
gesagt viele leute wissen nicht was das
ist
ich bin mit einem suisse aufgewachsen
und alan smith welcher der wohlstand der
nationen und unsichtbare hand
geschrieben hat sagte ich zitiere jeder
einzelne unternehmer verfolgt nur sein
eigenes materielles interesse und
kümmert sich nicht um das gemeinwohl
doch in dem er sein eigenes interesse
verfolgt trägt er zur ökonomischen
innovation bei und fördert damit das
gemeinwohl und das ist zwar etwas
zweifelhaft aber die analyse stimmt da
gibt es eine junge generation überall
auf der welt die sich selber social
entrepreneur nicht sie sind richtige
unternehmer durchaus aufs eigene
interesse bedacht aber sie erkennen dass
ihr unternehmerisches geschick davon
abhängt dass sie ihre kreativität mit
kostenloser software mit 3d gedruckten
produkten in der breiten sharing economy
und den commons austauschen
denn das hebt ihre soziale reputation
das mehrt ihr soziales kapital gibt
anerkennung die einen machen daraus geld
anderer wechseln in den non profit
sektor der sozialwirtschaft und werden
bezahlt für ihre dienstleistungen das
alte ideal des unternehmers nein es
entsteht ein besserer typ unternehmer
der nimmt das beste vom kapitalismus und
vom sozialismus und wirft das andere
über bord wir sind jetzt alle
unternehmer alle produzieren und
tauschen wir unsere eigenen güter und
dienstleistungen
wir haben den begriff ausgeweitet wir
lassen nur die machtfülle weg welche
großunternehmen im markt erlangen können
dann nehmen wir das beste vom
sozialismus wir teilen was wir schaffen
miteinander und niemand bleibt auf der
strecke
aber wir lehnen eine zentrale kontrolle
von oben durch die regierung ab das ist
keine utopie
ich glaube nicht an die utopie es ist
eine reise zum besseren
es gibt neue möglichkeiten und es wäre
schade nicht so weit zu gehen
man muss aber einfach so entschuldigung
von adams muss noch sagen dass er auch
noch ein zweites buch geschrieben hat
die theorie der ethischen gefühle war ja
sehr wohl die sympathie die empathie mit
den anderen menschen auch ins zentrum
gestellt hat und hat gesagt ökonomisches
handeln ist ich wünschte jeder mann
hätte sein zweites buch gelesen
schön dass sie sein zweites buch erwähnt
bei dieser übergangsphase sie stehen
dann jetzt ganz klar okay wir müssen
diese ganze infrastruktur bauen da gibt
es tonnenweise arbeit also wir brauchen
uns nicht vor arbeitslosigkeit zu
fürchten
und dennoch sind wir im moment an einer
nicht ganz einfachen phase wenn wir die
westlichen gesellschaften anschauen
man weiß ich so genau ich habe es am
anfang angesprochen die konjunktur zieht
nicht so richtig an wir haben nicht mehr
dieselbe sicherheit in unser
sozialsystem wir sollten sie reformieren
wir tun uns aber schwer damit das heißt
wir halten eigentlich am besitz
standfest und gleichzeitig erleben wie
so etwas wie einen neuen nationalismus
dass sich die leute eingespielte auf
sich selber beschränken
ich frage sie jetzt in der ersten
industriellen revolution aus der heraus
ist marx entstanden und was aus marx
entstanden ist das wissen wir mit dem
marxismus und sozialismus aus der
zweiten industriellen revolution sind
ebenfalls unschöne dinge entstanden wenn
ich an den nationalismus macht ihm vor
dem zweiten weltkrieg denke also immer
wenn es den menschen schlecht geht wenn
die arbeit abnimmt wenn sie nicht mehr
wissen wo ihre zukunft ist dann
generiert die solche systeme werden
stehen wir auch vor einer solchen phase
ja ja wir geraten in eine heftige
auseinandersetzung
es gibt auf der welt länder mit den
verschiedensten entwicklungsstufen in
einigen regionen herrschen noch immer
blut und stammesfehden in teilen der
welt gibt es krieg und die religion und
um theologische auslegungen gewisse
leute in einigen ländern führen immer
noch ideologische kontroversen zum
beispiel über den nationalfeiertag
aber trotz dieser schrecklichen dinge
erleben wir auch etwas anderes
es gibt eine jüngere generation der wii
im internet und im internet der dinge
begegnen diese weitet ihren blick auf
die ganze menschheit und auf dem
planeten auf dem wir leben
millionen junger menschen skypen in den
global classrooms sie kommunizieren
zusammen auf facebook sie sind die
größte virtuelle familie auf erden sie
plaudern miteinander auf twitter sie
werden gefahr dass sie teil einer
größeren gruppe genannt menschheit sind
und sie fangen gerade an ein bewusstsein
für die biosphäre zu entwickeln die
biosphäre ist interessant es sind die 40
meilen von der stratosphäre bis hinunter
zu meeresgrund in denen alles leben mit
den chemischen stoffen des planeten
interagiert um diese so genannte
existenz aufrecht zu erhalten
es gibt 14 jährige kinder mit kenntnis
der biosphäre
sie kommen nach hause und fragen warum
vergeudet ihr so viel wasser warum läuft
der fernseher wenn niemand schaut strom
verschleiß warum haben wir zwei autos
warum kein carsharing material zu sparen
und eine frage die mir besonders gefällt
woher kommt der hamburger auf meinem
teller
es gibt kinder die fragen kommt dieser
hamburger oder dieses rindfleisch aus
dem regenwald dann müssen sie ja bäume
fällen um die kuh grasen zu lassen
und wenn die bäume gefällt sind werden
auch tiere und pflanzen die um die bäume
leben ausgerottet und wenn um die kühe
zu weiden die bäume gefällt werden
können sie das co2 nicht mehr
absorbieren um den klimawandel
aufzuhalten
dann steigt die temperatur der erde und
manche bauern können nichts mehr
anpflanzen weil ihr land von dürre und
regen flut heimgesucht wird
die kinder lernen was der ökologische
fußabdruck ist sie lernen dass alles was
wir tun sich auswirkt auf andere
menschen auf andere lebewesen und auf
unser ökosystem
wir erkennen die notwendigkeit der
schering ökonomie anzugehören
wir können uns nirgends verbergen der
klimawandel ist ein weckruf und ein
drastisches lehrstück niemand entgeht
dem klimawandel auf diesem planeten
darum müssen wir die biosphäre als
unsere eigentliche community betrachten
wir müssen unsere nationalen religiösen
und verwandtschaftliche bindungen
deshalb nicht aufgeben aber wir müssen
anfangen in größeren zusammenhängen zu
denken
wir müssen mit der erde die wir bewohnen
in
frieden leben um das leben zu erhalten
wenn wir nicht rechtzeitig dafür reif
werden dann andere werden nach uns
kommen 99 prozent der spezies kommen und
gehen
es gibt hier keine garantie ich bin
voller hoffnung aber ich bin nicht naiv
und ich glaube wir sind am ende der
reise und schaffen es beizeiten in diese
neue welt
ich glaube auch dass ich das dass sich
das in die richtung bewegt wenn ich mir
aber dann trotzdem diese gesellschaft
vorstellen wie sie dann aussieht im jahr
2050 oder in 50 jahren dann stelle ich
mir vor ein teil ist sind die
spezialisten die kommen richtig die
haben richtig richtig gut gebildeten
verdienen richtig gut geld ein teil ist
lieferant das sind die die nicht so gut
gebildet sind und nicht so viel geld
verdienen weil die irgendjemand muss die
waren ja verteilen und dazwischen gibt
es die social engineers könnte das etwa
so aussehen
sie können laut case er sagte es schon
um 1930 ich erwähne ist im ersten
kapitel meines buches
es war die zeit der depression alle
hatten angst
er kritzelte ein brieflein seine
grosskinder und sagte alle reden von
diesen neuen begriff der technologie
verdrängung bei der neue technologien
schneller kommen als neue arbeitsplätze
geschaffen werden
damals hat es angefangen er sagte die
menschen fürchten um ihre arbeit aber es
wird die menschheit befreien
denn wenn wir diesen übergang schaffen
werden uns die maschinen alle arbeit
abnehmen und wir haben zeit für
wichtigeres den verstand einzusetzen für
die erforschung unseres lebens weges und
die ursache unseres daseins chains
kannte das wort sozialkapital noch nicht
aber das ist es was er damit meinte ich
glaube wenn wir das hinkriegen werden
unsere grosskinder in 50 jahren
vielleicht auf das zwanzigste
jahrhundert mit der gleichen abscheu
zurückblicken wie wir auf sklaverei und
leibeigenschaft sie werden denken unsere
großeltern verbrachten ihr ganzes leben
an werk plätzen in büros und
fabrikhallen ohne ihr gehirn groß
anzustrengen gedankenlos maschinen
steuern um dinge herzustellen was für
ein verlust an menschlichen werten
ich hoffe wir schaffen ist
wir können ist und die evolution des
menschen zeigt dass es dunkle zeiten
gibt niedergang und kollaps aber
allmählich verstehen wir besser wie wir
als spezies auf dieser erde weiter leben
können ich hoffe diesmal werden wir den
nächsten sprung schaffen diesen
kollaborativ kommen und wenn wir jetzt
wirklich nur auf die auf den menschen
schauen wie bewegt er sich darin und sie
beschreiben ja dass junge menschen die
millenniums generation sehr sich darauf
freut und findet das teilen ist schön
und sie sind dann teil einer großen
gesellschaft einer großen gemeinschaft
diktieren
sie verstehen sich und eigentlich nicht
zufrieden
in dieser in dieser vision schließen sie
ja eigentlich die etwas bösen charaktere
die wir unter uns haben eigentlich aus
ich meine es gibt immer menschen die
mächtig sein wollen es gibt immer
menschen die andere beherrschen wollen
in meinem buch befasse ich mich mit
solchen konflikten ich schließe sie
nicht aus ich sage die großen risiken
sind der cyber terrorismus der
klimawandel
dann geht es um datensicherheit und
transparenz seite um seite mühe ich mich
damit ab bitte seien sie nicht ungerecht
vor allem bin ich voller hoffnung ich
bin kein utopischer enthusiast das
beweist mein buch zweitens glaube ich
dass der konflikt von dem sie reden real
ist aber ich will ihnen etwas hoffnung
machen ein kleines kind das werden alle
eltern bestätigen wird schon im alter
von zweieinhalb jahren in die alte aus
wirtschaft und in die marktwirtschaft
eingeführt
die eltern geben ihm ein spielzeug und
sie sagen das ist ein spielzeug nicht
dass deines bruders und das deiner
schwester es ist dein besitzt rack sorge
dazu das kind lernt schnell mein
spielzeug niemand darf es sonst anrühren
das kind spielt eine zeit lang damit
dann kommt es in die rumpelkammer
doch nun gibt es eine ganze generation
von jungen eltern die es anders machen
sie gehen zu den kollaborativen commons
sie bezahlen eine gebühr und erhalten
einen kredit mit diesem bekommen sie ein
spielzeug für ihr kind das kind spielt
eine woche damit und dann nicht mehr
sie schicken es zurück an die schilling
economy website den kredit benutzen sie
um ein neues spielzeug auszuwählen
unterdessen geht das erste spielzeug
jemand anderem und so weiter und so fort
was lernt das kind dabei ein spielzeug
ist nicht etwas das man besitzt und
anderen vorenthält
es ist nur der zugang zu einer erfahrung
für eine gewisse zeit dann wird es mit
anderen geteilt
das ist ein perspektivenwechsel in
unserer denkweise über die
zwischenmenschlichen beziehungen wo es
um ökonomisches handeln geht und das
macht wirklich hoffnung kommen zusammen
verwalten sich selber und sie sprechen
bewusst nicht von regierung und trotzdem
frage ich sie wenn sie regierung beraten
wie sollen sich regierungen in dieser
schwierigen übergangsphase verhalten was
sollen sie tun und das ist etwas
verwirrend ich freue mich dass sich
vizekanzler sigmar gabriel in der
buchbesprechung sehr lobend über das
buch äußerte er sagte am anfang stehe
eine allgemeine theorie die uns einen
neuen bezugsrahmen für unsere
zielsetzung verschaffen es gibt uns eine
orientierung es ist keine lösung das
buch sagt bringen wir alles was wir säen
zusammen und fangen an die umrisse einer
neuen lebensweise auf diesem planeten zu
sehen
jetzt mögen sich unsere politiker die
geschäftswelt unsere schulen die eltern
und die zivilgesellschaft damit befassen
wie wir diese orientierung nutzen wollen
damit wir möglichst ohne unterbrechung
und so schonungslos ins neue zeitalter
finden aber ich bin nicht naiv ich war
sozial politischer aktivist wären 45
jahren
ich denke das wird hart es geht jetzt
vor allem darum dass wir rechtzeitig das
ziel erreichen ich hoffe es für alle
eltern die sich fragen wird mein kind
einen job finden werden wir auf einem
überlebensfähigen planeten leben wird
ihr künftiges leben eine bessere
qualität haben als unseres jetzt und ich
sage in meinem buch das ist alles
möglich wir müssen uns aber unbedingt
lösen vom gegenwärtigen zynismus denn
der führt in die verzweiflung wir können
ja ohnehin nicht
tun das wird doch alles von wenigen
unternehmungen übernommen so einfach ist
die geschichte nicht und ich gebe ein
beispiel die frage der monopolisierung
ist völlig in der abi aus dem frühen
fabrik system im neunzehnten jahrhundert
da gab es diese großen fabrik herren und
millionen verarmte leute die keine
aussicht hatten dass ihre kreativität
ihre physische und mentale energie je
gerecht entlohnt würde
sie waren ausgebeutet und bettelarm und
was taten sie
sie erkannten dass sie sich in
gewerkschaften zusammenschließen und
ihre forderungen den fabrik herren
gegenüber kollektiv stellen mussten
der rest ist geschichte es ist wohl naiv
zu glauben dass die menschheit sich
nicht für diese sache einsetzen wird die
ganze menschheit wird durch dieses
internet der dinge verbunden sein können
sie sich vorstellen dass die menschheit
zu keinem zeitpunkt erkennen wird dass
sie sich organisieren muss um eine neue
gemeinsame stimme zu erheben im
interesse der kreativität des
datenschutzes und ihrer inhalte
können sie sich vorstellen dass die
ganze menschheit schweigt und das feld
einer handvoll großunternehmen überlässt
das geschieht nicht
ich denke eher dass eine globale
kooperative entstehen wird der sich
jeder mensch sehr schnell anschließen
und sagen kann da sind wir und wir
wollen sicher sein dass das internet der
dinge offen und transparent ist und alle
inhalte und daten schützt und das wir
anerkannt sind zu glauben das geschehe
nicht verstößt gegen die geschichte die
menschen werden handeln und sich
organisieren und das wird zu konflikten
führen
aber wir haben gesehen
letzte frage wenn sie nächsten zehn
jahre vor sich sehen
wovor haben sie angst
ich habe keine angst ich bin vorsichtig
die frage ist nicht ob wir da hin
gelangen
es kann etwas passieren ein
katastrophales ereignis dass wir uns
nicht vorstellen können dass diesen
prozess stoppen könnte oder wie ich auch
schon sagte cyberterrorismus könnte sich
ausbreiten bevor wir das system
aufgebaut haben und unterhalten können
oder der klimawandel könnte noch rascher
voranschreiten als wir dachten aber was
etwa die erdöl interessen betrifft ich
glaube nicht dass man an die großen
erdölfirmen denken muss ihre zeit ist um
nicht morgen nicht in zehn aber in den
nächsten 40 jahren
wie sollen diese großen fossilen
energieträger wenn die preise dauernd
steigen wenn sie immer ausgefallenere
fördermethoden finden und klima steuern
zahlen müssen wie sollen sie sich noch
weiter steigern können
wo aber millionen menschen in den
kommenden 25 jahren ihren eigenen strom
wie heute schon in deutschland in
quartieren und firmen herstellen und zu
null grenzkosten teilen werden das
beunruhigt mich nicht ich mache mir aber
sorgen wegen netzen wie google facebook
und twitter obwohl ich auch da nicht all
zu viel angst habe denn wenn die
versuchen sich das alles ein zu
verleiden werden wir mit dieser
technologie einfach andere kommen zu
eröffnen
denn das große plus dieser commons ist
dass wir zu fast null grenzkosten
produzieren und teilen können
wenn die uns also in die zange nehmen
öffnen wir einfach ganz schnell andere
commons und so weiter ich denke die
geschichte steht auf der seite der
dritten industriellen revolution
aber es gibt noch so viele
unwägbarkeiten nicht voraussehbarer
konflikte und ich hoffe dass mein buch
eine orientierung gibt damit wird zu
einer globalen diskussion finden
das beste wäre wenn die menschheit sehr
schnell viel weiter ginge als dieses
buch und sich mit all den themen
auseinandersetzen würde und an die
eltern
dies ist die zukunft ihrer kinder sie
müssen handeln
ich bin verhalten optimistisch
dieser tage feiert das cern in genf
einen sechzigsten geburtstag juri
steiner lässt dazu den astrophysiker und
philosophen harald lesch zu einem
gespräch lassen sie sich mitnehmen in
eine reise durchs universum die zukunft
ist offen wir bleiben dran
[Musik]